"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
AS GEORGE ORWELL ONCE NOTED
THE WORST ADVERTISEMENT FOR
SOCIALISM IT S. ITS
ADHERENCE.
THE TYPICAL SOCIALIST IS
QUOTE EITHER A YOUTHFUL SNOB
OR A PRIM LITTLE MAN WITH A
WHITE COLOR JOB USUALLY A
SECRET TEETOTALER AND OFTEN
WITH VEGETARIAN LEANINGS.
ORWELL WROTE THOSE WORDS IN
1937.
WEIRDLY RECOGNIZABLE TODAY,
ESPECIALLY THE LINE ABOUT
VEGETARIANISM.
THERE IS SOMETHING ABOUT THE
LEFT YOU MAY HAVE NOTICED
THAT MAKES THEM HIGHLY
NEUROTIC ABOUT FOOD.
IT'S BEEN THAT WAY FOR
GENERATION.
BUT THERE IS AMPLE EVIDENCE
THE IMPULSE IS GETTING
WORSE.
HERE IS A CLIP FROM THE
OTHER NIGHT ON CNN.
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES LINING
UP TO DENOUNCE MEAT AS
IMMORAL.
>> BUT WOULD YOU SUPPORT
CHANGING THE DIETARY
GUIDELINES?
>> YES.
>> YOU KNOW THE FOOD
PYRAMID.
>> YES.
>> TO REDUCE RED MEAT
SPECIFICALLY.
>> YES, I WOULD.
>> IT'S GOOD FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT, IT'S GOOD FOR
YOUR HEALTH IF YOU EAT LESS
MEAT.
MEAT IS EXTRAORDINARILY
EXPENSIVE THING TO PRODUCE.
>> LOOK, THERE ARE A LOT OF
WAYS THAT WE TRY TO CHANGE
OUR ENERGY CONSUMPTION.
SOME OF IS WITH LIGHT BULBS.
SOME OF IT IS ON STRAWS SOME
OF IT IS DANG, ON
CHEESEBURGERS, RIGHT?
>> Tucker: ELIZABETH WARREN
SAYS YOU EAT TOO MANY
CHEESEBURGERS AS IF IT'S ANY
OF HER BUSINESS.
THAT'S THE THING.
SHE ACTUALLY THINKS IT IS
HER BUSINESS.
THEY ALL THINK THAT.
THE ACTIVIST LEFT SEEKS TO
CONTROL EVERYTHING YOU DO,
INCLUDING WHAT YOU PUT IN
YOUR MOUTH.
FOR THE LAST FEW YEARS THEY
HAVE BEEN PUSHING TO YOU EAT
BUGS.
REMEMBER THE HEADLINE FROM
"THE WASHINGTON POST,"
EATING BUGS CAN HELP THE
ENVIRONMENT OR HOW ABOUT
THIS ONE FROM THE "NEW YORK
TIMES," WHY AREN'T WE EATING
MORE INSECTS?
IT'S BIZARRE.
WHY WOULD THEY WANT YOU TO
EAT INSECTS?
BECAUSE EATING INSECTS IS
REPULSIVE AND UNAMERICAN.
AND, OF COURSE, THEREFORE IN
THE ICE OF THE LEFT, IT MUST
BE AWESOME.
THE MORE PERVERSE AND
UNNATURAL THE BETTER.
THAT HAS ALWAYS BEEN THEIR
STANDARD.
THEY ARE NOT LEADING A
POLITICAL MOVEMENT BY THE
WAY.
THEY ARE LEADING A REVOLT
BEGINS THEIR FATHERS.
GIVEN THAT WE SHOULDN'T BE
SURPRISED ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED ON TELEVISION THIS
WEEK WHEN A RESEARCHER
CALLED MAGNESS UNVEILED HIS
YOU REMEMBER.
EATING INSECTS IS NOT ENOUGH
ACCORDING TO HIM.
CUTTING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS MAY REQUIRE TO US
DEVELOP A TASTE FOR HUMAN
FLESH.
YES, IT IS TIME TO PRACTICE
ECOCANNIBALISM.
WATCH.
>> CENSUS TAKER ONCE TRIED
TO TEST ME.
I ATE HIS LIVER WITH FABA
BEANS AND A NICE CEANTE.
>> Tucker: SORRY, WRONG
CLIP.
YOU GET THE POINT.
PROFESSOR WENT ON TO SAY
UNFORTUNATELY MANY PEOPLE
MIKE BULK AT CANNIBALISM.
THEY ARE TOO UPTIGHT START
BY EATING THEIR OWN PETS.
HAVE A COCKER SPANIEL BURGER
FOR THE PLANET.
NOW, THE SWEDES WE SHOULD
TELL YOU ARE SEVERAL YEARS
AHEAD OF US IN THE U.S. IN
THEIR CLIMATE CONSCIOUSNESS.
WE WILL GET THERE SOON.
WHEN WE DO GET THERE IT WILL
BE DUE TO THE TIRELESS
EVANGELIZING EKE PROPHETS OF
SAINT PETE BUTTIGIEG OF
SOUTH BEND.
AS BUTTIGIEG ACKNOWLEDGED
THE OTHER NEED GOD HIMSELF
AGREES WITH EVERY WORD SAINT
PETE UTTERS.
>> IF YOU BELIEVE THAT GOD
IS WATCHING, AS POISON IS
BEING BELCHED INTO THE AIR
OF CREATION AND PEOPLE ARE
BEING HARMED BY IT,
COUNTRIES ARE AT RISK OF
VANISHING IN LOW LYING AREAS
WHAT DO YOU SUPPOSE GOD
THINKS OF THAT?
I BET HE THINKS IT'S MESSED
UP.
AT LEAST ONE WAY OF TALKING
ABOUT THIS IS THAT IT'S A
KIND OF SIN.
>> Tucker: HEAR THAT?
DISAGREEING WITH SAINT PETE
IS A SIN OR AS EPISCOPAL I
CAN'T
ICN'T
ICANT
ICAN'T
ASAN'T
AS E'T
AS EPISCOPALIANSPUT IT.
WHAT'S NOT A SIN FLYING ON
PRIVATE JETS WHICH SAINT
PETE DOES MORE THAN ANY
OTHER DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE
IN THE RACE.
OF COURSE IF YOU DID, IF YOU
WIND UP WITHIN 50 FEET OF A
PRIVATE JET THE LEFT WOULD
DENOUNCE YOU AS MURDERING
THE PLANET.
WHEN THEY FLY PRIVATE IT'S
VERY DIFFERENT.
IT'S NECESSARY.
IT'S NOT LIVE
IT'S NOT FIVE
IT'S NOT FRIE
IT'S NOT FRIVOLOUS.
THEY HAVE.
TO SAY IT'S VIRTUOUS.
ACTUALLY.
TWO STANDARDS ONE FOR THEM,
ONE FOR EVERYONE ELSE.
THEY ARE LIKE THAT WITH
EVERYTHING, BY THE WAY.
WATCH, FOR EXAMPLE, AS SAINT
PETE NEEDLES THE WEST OF US
PROLS ABOUT OUR NAUGHTY
PLASTIC STRAW HABIT.
>> I THINK WE ARE THINKING
ABOUT IT MOSTLY THROUGH THE
PERSPECTIVE OF GUILT FROM
USING A STRAW TO EATING
BURGER.
AM I PART OF THE PROBLEM?
IN A CERTAIN WAY, YES.
THE MOST EXCITING THING IS
THAT WE CAN ALL BE PART OF
THE SOLUTION.
>> Tucker: YOU JUST HEARD
IT.
WHEN YOU USE A DRINKING
STRAW, SAYS SAINT PETE OF
SOUTH BEND, YOU ARE PART OF
THE PROBLEM.
UNLESS YOU HAPPEN TO BE PETE
BUTTIGIEG HIMSELF AND YOU
FIND YOURSELF AT THE IOWA
STATE FAIR.
IN WHICH CASE YOU CAN EAT
ALL THE MEAT YOU WANT AND,
YES, YOU CAN DRINK FROM A
PLASTIC STRAW.
WATCH.
>> AND THERE IS NO LONG-TERM
PLAN.
>> THE USMCA HELP FARMERS?
>> ONE-ON-ONE.
>> DO THEY WANT TO KNOW
ABOUT POLICY OR DO THEY
WANT -- AND HOW DO YOU PITCH
SOMETHING LIKE A PLAN FOR --
HOW DO YOU DEMONSTRATE TO
PEOPLE HERE THAT YOU COULD
BE THE GUY?
>> Tucker: ARE YOU STARTING
TO FIGURE THIS OUT?
STRAWS FOR ME BUT NOT FOR
THEE.
DON'T LIKE IT, TOUGH.
STOP YOUR WHINING AND EAT